thibout tenía 18 años cuando fue
asesinado en 2006 recibió un disparo en
el momento en que se encontraba cerca de
una iglesia en chicago su madre pan bus
lee lo recuerda 16 años después y
condena a la violencia armada que
recorre el país
me quedé así sin él sin ninguna razón
sin razón aparente pero la violencia
armada parece seguir siendo un problema
importante en eeuu porque eeuu ama las
armas más de lo que ama a nuestros
jóvenes
desde entonces pan decidió dedicar su
vida a combatir la violencia armada como
ella muchos activistas luchan por
revertir las cifras de una ciudad como
chicago que en 2021 registros 797
homicidios más de dos al día y la cifra
recortes desde 1996
deje la banca después de estar allí
durante más de 20 años y fui a una
organización sin fines de lucro ganando
menos dinero porque quería ayudar a
alguien más porque no quería que otra
familia terminara pareciéndose a mi
familia con un hijo asesinado
mientras eeuu vuelve a tener la posesión
de armas en el centro del debate otros
activistas llaman la atención sobre las
posibles causas de los constantes
tiroteos que se presentan en el país no
hay una economía real en las comunidades
como las del sur y del oeste donde los
jóvenes pueden conseguir empleo donde
pueden cuidar a sus familias a una edad
temprana es duro es duro muchos jóvenes
salen a la calle para intentar llegar a
fin de mes pero a pesar de este tipo de
iniciativas las cifras de eeuu siguen al
armando todos los días más de 110
estadounidenses mueren por causas
relacionadas a armas de fuego y la tasa
de homicidios con pistola en el país
hasta 26 veces mayor que la de otros
países de altos ingresos